good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Tuesday it is a
beautiful sunny alfresco day here in New
York we're all spending it inside
another beautiful day where we're not
drinking sans hair alfresco and these
are the days that that heard that cut
Dean yeah the temperature is just like
sublime you think that the longer you
quarantine the more you'd get used to it
but honestly like when I go outside to
walk the I went it's so delicious out
like I actually want to lick the air
it's delicious nutritious and
superstitious so it makes it really
really hard I don't know what the
weather's like we're all you guys live
but it's absolutely in the words of my
sister sublime here in New York the sky
is blue it makes for a great backdrop
for our show so hey thanks for tuning in
is this your first time welcome to the
morning toast the Millennial morning
show we go live Monday through Friday
these days at noon time but typically at
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time and you know
what I'm officially adjusted to the noon
Eastern Time Big John waking up at 10:00
today was impossible no literally I now
I don't set an alarm but I wake up and
it's like I don't have time to lollygag
like I gotta get moving my bed do the
laundry get dressed I I set my alarm for
10:00 my snooze did until like 10:35 I
don't even settle on her oh I have to
set an alarm cuz I could sleep till 2:00
I slept the deepest I've ever slept well
not ever but in a really long time and
had the craziest dream like we were back
at camp I think it was because we were
talking about Camp Joe so I got like 6
o'clock last night it was like in my
brain yeah and we were just at camp and
they put all the sisters and a bunk
together and like they left me out of
the back which i think is just you know
really speaking on like my my true fear
missing out like my big like and it was
just like honestly a nightmare like you
guys having so much fun and I was like a
no loser bunk with people I'd never met
before
well I didn't realize I was having so
much fun last night yeah are you tired
that's why maybe I was so exhausted
yesterday I know I've been joking with
you guys but like there was just not
enough time in the day yesterday like
for all my new hobbies I just don't have
enough time to do them all in one day
like I had to clean my apartment from
top to bottom yesterday changed my
sheets put the new day cover on myself
like I was cleaning like on my hands and
knees again I guess you have to do that
like one so we get sweaty um I was
writing like breezy clothes so I wasn't
getting too sweaty and my apartment was
like a nice cool temperature um so I was
like scrubbing my apartment then we had
this like meeting at 5 o'clock then I
peloton that I needed to read then I had
to watch it toes maybe the day and the
day just like slipped away
and then I was onions ACK wanted
something different from dinner than
when I had so all of a sudden I'm
cooking two meals like I have children
oh my god what did you want him what did
he want
I just wanted pasta with marinara sauce
but he wanted this like ravioli that he
got and it sounds good and I had no
interest in ever eating it so I was like
I'll make it now because Passover is
coming up and we must eat all the cars
so yesterday I had not one but two
peanut butter jelly sandwiches and they
were so good I realized I had a loaf of
bread at my house and I'm so annoyed
that I found it today or yesterday
because we only have two more days
before we have to stop eating bread for
Passover so I'm trying to get through
the whole loaf before tomorrow I already
went through four slices and been and
had a tuna sandwich so he took two it is
the most delicious bread it's pepperidge
farm just like a regular whole-wheat but
I don't know why I'm acting like I've
never had bread before because we just
don't appreciate bread it is the big bad
breads the devil you know yeah unless
it's a popover no but there's so many
different brands of like loaves of bread
like in the store wonder and I've had a
lot and I never have felt like fulfilled
no I've never felt like impacted by a
piece of bread until like been just
bought and it was the only one left it
is
Pepperidge Farm whole wheat it is so big
and soft and fluffy it's so good and it
just really makes a difference in the
sandwich so like literally at midnight
last night I was so hungry I just like
made another sandwich because I was
feeling fat about and also because I
know you guys probably all saw my
Instagram story I made penne alla vodka
for dinner and what you didn't see was
me and Ben eating it and the whole thing
tasting like vodka and like us gagging
and having to throw away a whole pot
what it was so nice [ __ ] I know and I
didn't want to ruin the moment on
Instagram I'm not usually one to like to
take it but idolic wasn't in the mood to
admit to feed because I'm like this new
chef and everyone was already being like
that's not penne yeah yeah and but was
here's what's annoying I followed and I
have to call them out a food network
recipe and it said I followed to a tee I
measured I was so good and it said so
you do the olive oil the garlic and the
onions and then the vodka you do it
first to let it burn off it said 2 to 3
minutes I mean I'm working with a hot
plate I don't know if it's the same
level of hot so I did eight minutes just
to make sure the vodka was burnt off
first thing I do I eat it I'm like it's
like vodka it's like yeah and we
literally threw the whole thing away and
her bagels for the night Wow I was so
upset
it looked flames I would have never
known it looked great and I didn't want
to ruin the moment on Instagram and I
feel like weird about like lying you
know because I'm always like so real I
know
sometimes it's just like you just don't
want to admit your failures that's until
like the next day yeah
so here I have admitted my failures okay
well that's it cuz I did feel inferior
when I sought your pasta and I was like
I just used like Rao's marinara sauce is
absolutely and I do have a ryos vodka
sauce so maybe I'll be making penne alla
vodka that's so much easier I know but
I'm just I'm so hungry right now anyways
that was so exhausted last night by the
time I got off my feet like I I couldn't
even i watch the twist movie of the day
and I was so excited to go to sleep I
was like I'm gonna go to sleep early I
did not fall asleep until like 3:00 a.m.
nope the problem with this whole thing
is like I'm on a weird schedule part of
it being quarantined part of us of part
of it being that we now push back to
hours like my hours are so weird I like
want to go to bed early but I really
can't go to bed until like 12:00 or 1:00
oh my god it was infuriating I read my
book the farm tremon it's like so crazy
it's a weird thing to read before you go
to sleep cuz it just like makes you feel
weird oh yeah so I don't I don't know
where I need to finish it today so I can
start a good before you go to sleep book
I can't wait to recap our trust movie of
the day I have a lot of thoughts and I
just can't believe like the comments
people like regarding it as like this
you know gem of a movie that like nobody
knew about it just wasn't that it wasn't
bad but it was like not good
and I just Lily Collins was the only
thing that was good about it but well
we'll get it she was fabulous
we have been a pump rules is on tonight
and we'll assign another toast movie of
the day is there anything else on
tonight not that I'm aware of
okay so I guess oh but you know what I
never did get to do yesterday is talk
about One Tree Hill so you just remind
me when we get to our TV keep recap
segment I want to talk about One Tree
Hill yeah okay and I know Co has some
thoughts on it too mm-hmm he's
definitely like a Brooke and Lucas like
champion yes so I guess like without
further ado maybe it's time I mean not
that much has happened since yesterday
which is kind of why we were going to
Monday Wednesday Friday at but you guys
said like you would hear us talk about
like boxing are bad holes on the show
and you wouldn't care so um we'll just
get right into it
yeah and actually that's so funny that
you said that means that sounds like a
really weird conversation the other
night about like bleaching your [ __ ]
and Ben was like what's the point I'm
like well because like you're [ __ ]
dark and like you would want to make it
light and he and I were going back and
forth as to what makes a butthole dark
he thinks they don't I don't want to
know what he think he thinks that like
your skin around your butthole is like
stained from duty from like from the
time of yours
and I'm like I just don't think that's
true I know I just think like the skin
is but darker pigmented by your butthole
I do you think I don't know I never have
ever thought about it and just take
yourself out of your body I also thought
that like when you bleach your butthole
you're bleaching the hair
oh no but I may be wrong no I do
bleaching the skin okay you're bleaching
the skin
yeah like have you ever seen like a
butthole of a pornstar I think it's like
pink and white like it's not like a real
bottle oh wow I uh I'm not educated
enough about buttholes
well they do they're on Shahs of Sunset
Reza and MJ got their ass holes bleached
which is why I know more about it than
the average you know person and so Ben
and I were just wondering like what
makes the skin around your butthole dark
is it like Jeanette like is it
biological like is it do Ben thinks it
was genuinely stained from joking it's
not because I'm like that's disgusting
and yeah and then you made a good point
like a baby's butt hole isn't brown I do
I eat it not I don't know I don't know
but I think maybe it's cuz it's like
more of your like inner like it's like
the inside of your mouth is darker than
the color of your face but it's still
technically your epidermis I'm talking
about the skin around about whole not
the bottle I don't know but it goes in
and out so it's like hanging out with
the people inside and I know it's
definitely like vs. protect itself from
the light you know no I just think that
like okay well you do bleach the skin I
had absolutely no clue
hopefully someone on the YouTube
comments will shed a little light on why
this could get into the fast side
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast I'm sorry we have a doctor
in the comments they said the skin
between your butt cheeks and directly
surrounding your anus is generally
darker than your actual skin color this
can result from friction hormonal
changes and excess pigment that's like
not an answer no I know but it's not
stained from due date so I mean we I
could have told you that like Ben is
such an eighth grader and like the fact
that you would say oh a doctor is here
when like literally doctor for timing is
right here he's okay [ __ ] you some
people say that in front of him he's off
the clock he is off the clock I've been
actually re watching our show because I
have nothing to do and I don't know how
people like don't complain more about
the fact that I don't speak English oh
how so I just like swallow sentences
like I literally will replay something
and even I can't understand it I don't
know like I'm really just gonna try to
speak English today
okay even the way I just said that
English today I just take a breath
between words you know okay
good luck yeah whatever I'll let you
know if I need any clarification our
first story is actually some answers to
a lot of questions that people have had
bachelor Peter Weber talks about being
in quarantine with Kelly Flanagan quote
we have good chemistry
so Peter Webber is on Nick vials podcast
the bio files today and he's nick is
asking the important questions and
peter's actually giving some other
[ __ ] answers long story short him and
kelly are not dating
why mm-hmm he said she's always been
supportive of me long story short I
wasn't working so I thought I'd go out
there to Chicago and spend some time
with her take her mind off of some
family things
this was right when everything was
starting to hit with the quarantine
stuff and it kind of just became a thing
where we've always gotten along really
well and had really good chemistry we
just joy enjoy each other's company are
we dating
no do I love spending time with her
absolutely we're not dating could I see
that in the future yeah of course I'd be
extremely lucky and very happy if that
happened of anyone and the last person
that needs to rush into any kind of
relationship I just had an engagement
that didn't work out I was trying to
pursue things with another woman that
didn't work out that's why right now I'm
just taking it really really slow he
even said I mean he said that there's in
different bedrooms in the house there's
three rooms in the house and that
they're not dating but now it's like
okay I want to take it at face value
they're not dating they're just friends
and I even got like a friendly vibe from
them on the show like she's obviously a
very respectable woman she she wasn't
lying on your live stream they are not
dating but like what is dating even mean
in quarantine like they're not going on
dates because they can't go until like
living together get something they're
not [ __ ] right that's the question
are you [ __ ] and it's like no one
wants to ask it because it's so crude
right but it's like dating is not a
thing anymore so if you ask someone if
they're dating it's an irrelevant
question we're not we're not going on
dates it's so hard for me to report on
this story when like I genuinely like
despise Peter like I just I'm still mad
at him for like wasting our time at that
whole season and even the way he's been
acting after the season ends between his
awful like cringe-inducing tick-tocks
and just his overall demeanor like I'm
just so over him but I am like someone
interested in whether or not they're
dating because I love Kelly and they do
really feel like she was always too good
for him and now in real life it's made
even more apparent that she is too good
for him
I'm unclear a little bit on the timeline
of this all because when we first saw
them like frolicking in Chicago is he
saying he was at her house for two weeks
before that not two weeks but he was
traveling and he stopped in Chicago to
see her and then I think quarantine were
being put into place and they probably
decided we were ready quarantine but
that's true every other city is kind of
was kind of like behind New York and LA
um and so and probably other cities that
I just they count between New York and
LA which we don't know but like those
were the big ones yeah and maybe see
honey we're like the first one and no
Seattle was the first big one so like we
were ahead of all this whatever this is
not CNN and so they have like a little
bit more time like legroom wiggle room
um to figure out what they were gonna do
and I think they just decided like hey
let's do this together they probably saw
the quarantine crew down in Florida more
like if they can do it so can we
well they're now taking a page out of
Tyler Cameron and had a Browns book and
being annoying on tick tock and don't
get me wrong I love Kelly but my
patience is wearing thin when it comes
to the tick tocks
and it's just so crazy how tick tocks
can make you just think totally
differently of a person you know I could
like love someone and watch our tic TOCs
and think they're so annoying or I could
hate someone but then like find them is
to be so endearing and funny on tick
tock tick tock is this weird platform
where it's changing hearts and minds
yeah I agree but I feel like actually it
does make me think more positively about
certain people that I didn't before yeah
I'm saying it has both effects yeah I
mean I know it's like way more in the
negative column of course I mean I've
had to block so many people just because
the algorithm if you don't know tick
tock it's like you don't follow people
and then see their content it's just
this this page of like literally
everyone in the world's content and
certain things rise to the top so like I
was getting literally every day a video
from Perez Hilton and that's just not
what I need like for my mental health
and just like the stability of the world
it's just not what I needed
it's why unfortunately I had to block
him yeah just so he would stop coming up
like shirtless on my [ __ ] for you
have to do what you have to do if for my
own mental health and I'll see your team
Charlie yeah and he was just like so
nasty like literally this old man
talking about like young girls he's just
out of control so you know what it's
actually that's my mental health tip of
the day start blocking people on
tick-tock it'll really change your life
I hadn't even known that you could do
that yet or also there's just people who
have like shtick that like comes up on
my case not yours and it's just not my
vibe there's some that are my vibe you
know
paradise bartender now oh my god she's
so cute she's she every video was like
her making a drink so she's like and I
think shields in Hawaii but she's been
bartending from home and she's like okay
guys I'm gonna show you how to make a
cucumber gimlet first you take a couple
of guys 1/2 ounce of vodka one to two
ounces of rum one two three four now
you're gonna put it in your shaker and
you're gonna give it a good shake shake
shake shake shake they're gonna give you
a nice strainer give it a nice good
strain and this gets garnished with a
lime and a lemon wedge like she's so
cute and that's a [ __ ] I could deal with
you know and let people have started
like recreate and those are the ones
that I need to block but so unless some
of the cooking ones are key but some
people just come across money even
there's this kid who like I think he
lives on 30th and Lex because I've
noticed the UM the building he gets on
his balcony every day like at 7 o'clock
when people are cheering and he gets
it's like he must be a DJ because he
gets his huge speaker and plays like a
journey song and like thinks he's
inspiring the block and I'm sure people
would just annoyed honestly thinks he's
like Kiera froggies husband he gets on
the with a corona beer
oh it's Corona and he's like dancing and
like filming people like reacting to him
and they're just they're they're out for
the 7 o'clock clap they're not out to
listen to music
it comes on my for your page every day
he's never seen any of these things that
you're talking about what that's so
weird
I should like swap talked I heard that
you get like your algorithm of your for
you page on tick-tock has something to
do with your geographical location and
that kids in New York which is why I
always get it oh I mean that makes sense
that we're in the same gene stations we
know but I think it also has to do with
other videos that you like like what
your vibe is I think I get a lot of like
fashion tik-tok errs that's actually
what I get a lot of little bloggers like
switching their outfits it's like we get
it like no stress no J jump no stress no
dress oh oh
like we [ __ ] you can get it you can jump
and change your outfit so that's I get
so many of those like bootleg like
Britney Xavier videos now like she's a G
yeah but then everyone like trying to be
her yeah want to be Xavier 's and I get
like so many people like life styling
videos of like people's apartments just
clean with like nice meals so I made
that too and a filter and like what you
do
Plus Oh Jackie the song don't
[Music]
I make a cup of coffee and it's always
like that making them like caramel
macchiato yeah it's like ice and like a
mason jar oh by the way we're talking
about the same girl I actually know that
because she goes like date one yeah yeah
yeah her [ __ ] videos keep coming up
in my chick talk she's a makeup and she
like even shows herself washing her bot
like her arm with a loofah oh god ray
whatever like filter she's filming her
own video and it's fabulous
yeah that's so funny I literally got her
videos every day it's like day 18
quarantine she does the same thing every
day but like videos different parts of
it
she makes the coffee like plates with
her dog takes a shower and then like
makes dinner yeah I'm saying same but I
guess I just don't have that filter it's
not depressing like she doesn't have
that patient yeah yeah her apartment
also then but like it must take her so
long to make those videos and all dead I
can't okay well anyways for the record
Kelly and Peter are not dating um
obviously question about whether or not
they're [ __ ] still up in the air I
just think it's a really weird thing for
like them both to do to quarantine with
each other like they barely know each
other they like used to date but they're
not dating and then they have like it's
just like it's like a shelter like for
all these random people just to come in
- yeah
it's it is interesting but I wonder like
if I were still single and I was like
living with like when I lived with Libby
and Danny like where would be a
quarantine it would have quarantined in
New York Harbor like together yeah I
don't know maybe that of hartman would
have been clean finally then maybe it's
a crazy time those were crazy times so
like yeah maybe we would have just been
like inviting people over to come
quarantine with us me because just being
crazy like young kids yeah Sam's in the
city totally just makes you think you
know when you guys all live together you
also lives in the same apartment
building as Bill Nye oh yes we did that
was weird yeah I mean it was very
glamorous building Vanessa Hudgens also
lived in it when she was on Broadway and
Vanessa I'm hundred that's an hundred
say wouldn't want us I hadn't used I
wouldn't want to offend use with the
other surgeons okay
next story is like really sad because
Michael che has announced that his
grandmother has died from coronavirus
did you see these no no Jesus okay so
Michael che announced on Instagram on
Monday that his grandmother died from
coronavirus and he posted a really long
bit of text on his Instagram like
literal ten slides and like he
isolates between being like angry and
funny and confused and wanting to blame
coronavirus on 5g because he like just
can't make sense of the fact that his
grandma died because someone ADA back
right it's so true and honestly the
statements like really funny and also
really sad and he just like you know was
being like going through all the
emotions of grief um and he said quote
I'm doing okay considering I'm obviously
very hurt and angry that she had to go
through all that pain alone but I'm also
happy that she's not in pain anymore and
I also feel guilty for feeling happy
basically the whole gamut of complex
feelings everybody has losing someone
very close and special I'm not unique
but it's still scary oh my god that's so
sad I've been hearing such had stories
about people who's like older
grandparents or parents are passing away
alone in hospitals and it's just like
the saddest thing ever
yeah it's really sad and like honestly
when he was when I read what he said it
really just like struck with me when he
was like I just refused to believe that
I lost my sweet beautiful grandma
because some n-word a tab at one time no
it's so crazy like and there's an is
there like a definitive and I'm sure
this is like a loaded question but is
there a definitive answer as to how
coronavirus got started like everyone
has theories okay so everyone does have
theories there are some conspiracy
theories like now with Spidey have you
heard this one yet and Ben was telling
me about it but I started to look it up
because I was like cuz now Michael J
wants to believe that it's hygiene so
basically people are thinking that like
you know how five G is like coming up
they've been saying it's coming for five
years yeah yeah no but like it's being
implemented in cities I guess it's
something with like the wireless or
whatever to make it stronger better
faster stronger harder better faster
stronger yes so the theory is that like
that technology like compromises your
mutant system and like is making people
sick are they like contributing to the
spread of coronavirus but no to answer
your question the disease is found in
this virus of coronavirus is found in
bats so it's like it went from that to
human being
um how probably someone ate a bat oh so
they don't know they don't know who the
person is who ate the bat and like I was
even even read an article that was about
like patient zero in wuhan but she said
she probably got it from the bathroom at
the market so it's like she wasn't
saying she ate yeah of course I would
want to admit that
yeah calls Michael chase grab on a
million other people to die I just I
can't understand and you know there's so
much politics around this like it's just
it should be something that's universal
like now it's like this whole political
thing we're like if you believe one
thing like so I'm just really not like
trying to like get involved but I just
want to know like how this happened
there's also of course I think the
people like me who think that this may
or may not have been cooked up in a lab
and that it may or may not have been
accidentally leaked yeah I don't think
that this was I mean I don't I'm not
gonna like go hard in on conspiracy
theories but a part of me believes that
like this was like in Wuhan they do have
a lab where they make they test these
sorts of diseases so like it's possible
that it leaked you know from below
testing it they got it and then they
went out into the world people just like
chill around and create viruses for what
reason to try and create yours create
cures understand them better and then it
depends but like sometimes in like
biological warfare scenarios just like
people you know make nukes just to have
in their arsenal they make diseases just
in case this is very um similar to like
what I feel could be a storyline of the
next Kingsman oh for sure samuel
l.jackson he has this disease he's gonna
unleash on the world know for sure it's
very King's mini I like I'm sure they
already fill my third but maybe they'll
do a fourth it's the corona virus or
late in yeah and you know what I was
thinking because you know tonight is the
series finale of shits Creek which I've
been watching the season I'll watch it
in fall yeah it's kind of sad because I
would have loved a season where like the
quarantine hits shits Creek but like no
one ever leaves the creek or comes in
there actually
roars but Motel would be the center of
the virus edgewood or Edgemont or
whatever i don't think they ever gonna
have a problem i said hope a lot of TV
shows like i mean i don't know how you
don't this is literally the biggest
cultural event since i don't know why
right like curb has to do a quarantine
season but they're done i know it's so
crazy crazy project anyways i feel sad
for michael che me too
love when people share grief because i
feel as though it's universal but this
is really sad yeah really sad if you
have a chance to read his statement
becomes
he is well-spoken um next up Kristin
Cavallari returns home after coronavirus
isolation in the Bahamas for three weeks
there's a lot of tea around this story I
read our Twitter thread about it
yesterday I think the timing is you know
people are pissed yeah as the kernel
iris crisis heightens Kristin Cavallari
has returned home from a trip abroad
with her family the star was in the
Bahamas for about three weeks with her
husband Jay Cutler and their three kids
they were also with Kristin's best
friend and hairstylist Justin Anderson
and his fiance scoot on what was
supposed to be a spring break vacation
so if you've been following them they
were quote-unquote stuck in the Bahamas
during quarantine however she posted it
from New York City on the day that New
York City went on I think it was March
12 or March 13th which was the day that
we all started quarantine then she went
home to Nashville and from Nashville she
went to the Bahamas so she went to the
Bahamas in the middle of quarantine and
then got stuck and then like made it a
narrative look we can come on yeah but
like you knew that when you loved and
you know what honestly my dream is to be
like quarantined on vacation there's an
article about this a couple who went on
their honeymoon and got stuck in the
Maldives because they couldn't get back
to South Africa where they're from and
on the one hand it's like that's the
dream on the other hand everyone's
pissed at these people who are like
going to islands taking up their
resources like infecting yeah potential
locals um and then there's another oh
the other piece to it is like you went
on this trip in the middle of
coronavirus and then are surprised that
you're still there even that honeymoon
couple like they thought it wouldn't
apply to them yeah I mean it applies to
Kristin and Jay but I actually think
they went on this trip purposefully
hoping it away hoping to get stuck there
yeah I don't know I feel like you know
I'm not someone who's gonna judge other
people's like level of social distancing
but this is something that I think we
spoke about briefly when we were
reporting on the Arielle Charny stuff
it's like you know what do what you want
to do is a free country but like when
you have a platform and you know how
like nuts people are like just stop at
some point like stop [ __ ] sharing so
with Kristin Cavallari like do I really
care that she won't have a case you know
but like people do and just the fact
that they were posting so much like
we're stuck we're stuck when in fact
like it really wasn't like that just put
your phone down like that would really
like get rid of half your problems yeah
and also you can't be stuck if you have
access to a private plane and you're not
in the country where there is a travel
there so they're in the Bahamas which is
not a long flight from Nashville at all
maybe maybe two hours they have the
means to get a plane they could have
left at any any point yeah and now
they're back in Nashville now they need
to self quarantine for two weeks um I
agree like just stop like we're owning
it in everyone's face yeah that's the
problem with all these like
quote-unquote cancellations that have
happened during quarantine it's mostly
due to the fact that like the
celebrities and influencers who are
getting in trouble it's just because he
didn't stop posting like all right I get
that you're like an authentic influencer
and like you have to post every moment
of your life but like at some point like
take a look at this from a PR
perspective and put your [ __ ] phone
away like right you got stuck in the
Bahamas you don't need to post a million
times the pictures of all you guys
drinking in the on the ocean that you
guys got it stuck in the Bahamas but in
fact you didn't get stuck because you
left during the quarantine and you know
what the thing is so many celebrities in
like normal times in a Norman team yeah
they're so elusive and invasive if they
don't post a social media they don't
even have such me that we never know
what they're doing we never guys say
they never give us answers and they're
so happy to like not post them when they
post it's literally like a national news
story yeah but now all of a sudden
during quarantine they can't stop no
everyone's just like an influence and
nobody cares I mean actually Pete
Kristin Cavallari is an influencer and
she is always posting so it is her job
to post but I also think one she thought
that people would like think it was
funny and cute and I think a lot of
people didn't - she doesn't give two
shits what people think about her yeah
like she's also an anti back sir um and
she just it's always like done whatever
she wants she that's rebel like that
sure of her you know at the beach on
9/11 or whatever
no the picture of her on the beach was
social distancing but she had a picture
in New York City like of her lady
fabulous yeah but she doesn't care which
I kind of respect I was gonna get no she
we're never gonna hear from her about
this like you know what I actually like
that like people who don't feel the need
to release a written statement every
time like there's a couple mean tweets
about them right and you know what like
as much as we could be like you know
this was irresponsible if I could have
been in the Bahamas during this
quarantine I would have been there in a
flash Oh totally we're all just jealous
I had a house in the Hamptons I would be
there in the flash that's like the way
people talk about Megan
like 90% of the time like we're just
jealous yeah but with mega market looks
different cuz like where you're never
gonna be a royal sorry to break the news
to you but like you you could look
Kristin Cavallari yeah you could have
gone to the Bahamas and ya could have
you would have of course and yeah shut
up I just wish I had had like a month
long trip planned but I just can't see
out with the people who left like who
left the country like when the
quarantine is very much in effect and
things stuck yeah like hell we say like
I would leave the car leave the country
when the car came is very much in effect
and be like whoo suck us out
ya know it's so dumb but that's just um
that's just life as a celebrity I know
it well and people really are is just
like getting super nitpicky now you know
yeah well people are bored and people
are pissed and people are annoyed and
honestly they're just taking it out on
the people who it's easy to take out
other people with private jets and trips
to the bomb ya know and now it's become
like a celebrity se posts about their
going to the grocery store to get
essential items they're wearing a mask
where'd you get that man oh by the way
masks is literally like now the new like
controversy ya know but then it's like
subber you goes to grocery store to got
the essential items and not wearing a
mask why aren't you wearing a mask
totally I went to a bodega did I tell
you so now it's like you can only be
wearing a scarf or a bandana used as a
mask or else sorry
cancelled I went to a bodega like in New
York but I got to pick up some like
snacks and literally behind the counter
where they sell like cigarettes they had
Ziploc bags with masks in them for $3
each I love to see it so honestly it's
not that hard to get masks it is hard to
get masks oh my god it's even harder to
get Clorox wipes I'm running low and I
mean I just got an unused um
stab box like because I never bought for
quarantine I just always had in my boss
for quarantine either because I never
used them as much as I do now and I
thought I was keeping both boxes in my
kitchen and I'm running low on those two
boxes and then I kind of third in my
bathroom a box of Clorox wipes a tube
what do you call it - yeah I was like
you have a box of tubes no it's a tube
it's an extra-large tube I'm literally
so jealous thanks anyways so that's what
the slugs are up to next story is very
exciting because the Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills tag lines are here look at
they are and they are splendid well they
have to be yeah we were talking about
yesterday about and I actually got a lot
of gm's about this conversation about
the production
companies and like the different styles
they bring to different franchises and a
lot of people and I definitely agree
we're saying like whoever produces
Atlanta which I think is the it's called
peach because Georgia they do a fabulous
job like they have this real elegance
and style that they bring and that is
always reflected in the taglines as well
and Weber produces Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills is also a top-tier
top-tier production company she's not
really arcing forward let me know hit me
with them okay first up Kyle Richards
something about a zip code around here
there's more than just dresses in
everyone's closet so it's still about
the community around here zip code in
Beverly Hills she could have said in
Beverly Hills it always talks about like
the town yeah and so she's staying true
to herself Lisa and I let me think I
mean Lisa Rinna's something about
dancing mm-hmm oh the secret to life
dance like everyone's watching oh my god
I love her that's fabulous I love that
um something about like fashion clothes
glam I won't settle for anything less
than everything oh that's very very cute
Garcelle Oh something about acting like
shoes and won't act with her real
friends or something
life is an audition and honey I'm
getting that part that's excellent
excellent Teddy oh oh she's pregnant so
like new birth a rejuvenation new new
face you never know what to expect when
I'm expecting oh that's really good
mm-hmm Erika Jayne Broadway star living
her dreams break a leg
not in these heels honey excellent yeah
the way you did ourselves was so funny
Denise Richards oh I don't know who I
think has the best one Oh
my life may not be a fairy tale but I'll
always get a happy ending oh that's good
that's really really good they're really
good what about Sutton Sutton doesn't
have a tag line yet because she probably
doesn't become a housewife until the
middle of the season
that's so weird yeah I don't know I'm
like showdown for garceau
this is so exciting I mean this is so
exciting I'm actually like counting on
that he's like like my heart is actually
beating really I usually don't look
forward to a new season I just like
these existing seasons that we're in and
like getting new episodes but like I am
so I always get so excited for Beverly
Hills cuz it just straight out the gate
it's poppin' but we cuz by the way this
is the greatest time of year in New York
and Beverly Hills always premiere like
near each other and it's just always an
exciting time to be a housewives fan but
honestly like with the really lackluster
New York premiere with like the sad tag
lines in the sad theme song like the
whole weird sad vibe Beverly Hills is
making me like really really excited and
I'm really excited about Garcelle I'm
really excited about the ladies without
Lisa because last season without Lisa
was so fabulous like should they thought
like the show wouldn't go on without
Lisa but like honestly all the women are
really good friends
and I think that's why it's always so
good it's like no matter who comes and
goes like the core people are always
really good friends like I know that
Teddy Kyle
and Teddy Kyle and Teddy and Kyle are
really good friends off-screen Lisa
Rinna
dorita and Eric are really good friends
so it's just like nice and Erica I mean
Doreen and Teddy are good friends
because their kids hang out they still
are good friends yeah well I don't know
right now but like I have seen the
interested oh really cause like for a
while they seemed like show friends like
good enough for the show but not like
rating out there's relationships like
intertwine yeah I mean and that's why
like it exists off air and then when
they come back on air it's like still
really good but that's what always the
problem is with New York they film right
after the summer and I guess people in
Beverly Hills don't do summers like
people in New York do because everyone
gets like a big house in a pool so they
do that oh we summer in Beverly Hills
yeah but in New York like people flock
and none of the ladies see each other
it's just so boring to like see them
catch up with each other like up until
Thanksgiving they don't really hang out
yeah yeah I feel like in Beverly Hills
like in summer they just like go to
Italy you know we're like yeah and then
they're back but then they're back in
their mansions with their pools and
their pool boys yeah totally I'm so
freaking stoked it was we're fabulous
tagline fabulous like I'm just so
excited so many of my favorites like to
read in Erica I I think ourselves was my
favorite say it again um sorry life's an
audition life's an audition and honey
I'm getting that part oh I love her
that's your like I think my fav I mean
honestly
they're also good I think my favorites
is Denise because it's like makes the
most sense yeah um but I love I love
Lisa Rinna's it's just so funny how the
point of a tag line has really evolved
because when it first started it was
like really one sentence that defines
you like I'm a doctor and a wife you
know like it was and now it's just more
like a mantra yeah I mean it we'd love
to see an evolution I think also in the
beginning it was something that they
said in the season you know they're like
how about liking Jersey Shore is like
Patty's yeah and then they would just
say it over but um it's become really
refuge' at all
it's become a really big thing and I
really don't think there's any excuse
for bad tag lines at this point because
the fans always give tagline oh my god
you know if what if Ramona tweeted like
I need a tagline for the season she
would get a hundred great response no I
followed like four or five really really
big Housewives fans and every year they
come up with like potential tag lines
and they're they're good enough to be on
air yeah and it's important you watch it
every episode yeah the New York ones are
so and the best ones stick with you of
course you either love me or hate me
there's no in-between with me and the
best ones speak to the season like you
can throw me to the wolves but leading
the pack that's a good one the crown is
heavy darling leave it where it belongs
actually you know what even though I
hate her at a glance where I was iconic
life isn't always diamonds and rose a
but it should be yeah good stuff
okay fifth and final story one world
together at home telecast will span
major networks feature lady gaga Paul
McCartney Liz Oh Billy Eilish and more
so music live streams at global citizen
has been webcasting on a daily basis to
promote promote the world health
organization initiatives during the
current virus pandemic now have
considerably more spectacular outgrowth
the two organizations have announced one
world together at home a global special
that will be seen and heard across major
broadcasting cable networks and it's a
digital music providers on April 18th I
just like I want to be excited about
this but I can't stand more [ __ ]
celebrities in their pajamas at all I
agree and so instead of being negative
I'm gonna say I'm excited about this for
the people who are going to watch what
am i me you know unfortunately has plans
but I'm excited for you Jackie actually
yesterday you said something that really
spoke to me and it's like we've been so
negative lately and it's just so hard
for me like even when I was watching
love Rosie I'm like I had such a
negative attitude but I'm like it's
gonna turn around and I'm gonna love it
and that obviously did not happen so I
was wondering if like you being the
beacon of light and positivity that you
could maybe impart some wisdom to both
me and people at home who are just
feelings shut like I've been actually
realized yesterday after you said like
everything I say is like I'm making fun
of people I'm saying and that's usually
the case but it's been another level up
in another level I mean for me too like
I literally had to take a few days to
self reflect and be like this is a tough
time for sure and everyone's going
through it people at home like even when
I say I'm feeling Moody like people can
relate to that but like we're in
people's homes every single day and I
don't want to contribute to anyone
else's moodiness and I definitely don't
want to yuck anyone Zeon's you know what
obviously there are some people who are
watching these concerts because they
keep putting them on so true and to
those people I say congratulations
you got a show now if I could talk about
all the canceled things that I like that
didn't get picked up again maybe I could
get a show too
yeah but yeah it's it takes effort to
like just stay above the line that's
what I'm like it's hard again it's like
it's hard but it's worthwhile because I
felt so much better after yesterday's
show then I did after Thursday show
where I was just like why am I being an
[ __ ] why am i hating on all these
celebrities who you know what even if
like it's cringe-worthy they are trying
to make people feel better I know but
it's also like self-serving and they're
just like they're telling me to be
strong and like you telling me to be
Sherman doesn't make me any stronger
yeah also we run an entertainment show
and it's more often than not funnier to
be mean that it is to be like light and
positive and funny and airy yeah but
it's also it's just you don't want that
to be your legacy like I think right
people like being a celebrity
commentator like it's so easy and even
funnier sometimes to just be mean but
then you're just like that mean person
and then like you're gonna die and go to
the gates and they're gonna be like
you're mean oh you're worried about
rolling up to the game you know I'm just
worried about like the like I'm thinking
of one person in particular who like at
back in the day like did a similar job
that we do not Joan Rivers like someone
if I said I just don't want to talk
about that because
I know I know you know who it is um and
it's just like I don't want that to be
my legacy I know and how people think of
me
yeah that's true but in an age of
quarantine it's much harder to stay
above that line you have any words of
wisdom my words of wisdom would be this
too shall pass
we're gonna come out bigger and better
and stronger as a party or the parties
are gonna be crazier and louder and
rowdier and you know what I'm never sure
gonna play together I'm burnish parties
called for Ted I'm showing up at 8:30 to
help you said Jackie G know what today
was 2 years ago
Ben's nineties birthday party that was
so fun we got there too late we got
there too late and I did show up early
to set up but like we just didn't have
enough fun and like everyone like you
know what like want people like left and
went to another club like I will never
do that again like I will never take a
party for granted and that's what's been
really hard about watching all these new
seasons of Housewives is that the
seasons really just revolved around
different moments at parties and all
they want to do is go to these parties
yes so like just think of those parties
like and you know what when that time
comes you're gonna like have so many
parties to go to you're not gonna have
time to rest and lay in bed and watch TV
so like get all that out of your system
now cuz good times are around the bend
and you know what even though it's
Sancerre alfresco season it's also
allergy season and the fact that we
don't have to like be like all wheezy
and sniffly and like with the pollen
right now we're just gonna graduate to
like summer fun but you just cruise
right past that moment that's nice yeah
ok let's dive into our TV recap section
before I forget I need to tell you about
One Tree Hill I started watching for
those who people been asking me where to
watch it it's not helu all nine seasons
and I just started watching it because I
truly had nothing else to watch and I've
been looking for just like a nice big
chunky show with a lot of seasons that I
could just dive into and of course I
went into it with a negative mentality
because that's what I do and I'm glad I
stuck with it because everyone was like
the first two seasons aren't really
there like cringy and weird but the
after the third season it's literally
the best show and I'm in the middle of
the second season and I'm not gonna lie
like I'm absolutely loving it and Ben is
loving it too like we watch it every
night before bed and he made a really
good call like maybe this show isn't
that good but every time you watch the
episode they start the episode with the
theme song which is I don't want to be
by Gavin DeGraw and it just like makes
you want to like the show there's so
many things about the show like that I
could die about you know it's so cringy
like it's high schoolers acting like
they're 30 it's everything you hate
about like the Riverdale's
but it's on ecstasy I just have to say
something that high-schoolers acting
like they're 30 he's like I think it's
so destructive because when you're 30
like we are now like you watch it you're
like what the [ __ ] these people are in
high school and when you're in high
school you're like am I supposed to be
30 no am I supposed to be living with
Jake with his baby like it's just it's
soaked and like it's so destructor
there's no parents and it all but he has
a parent like I feel like we need to do
a better job of like high school shows
reflecting like the real high school
situation like even the fact that Lily
Collins was playing an 18 year old and a
10 year olds 31 like totally but with
with One Tree Hill the problem with the
show is that you genuinely despise so
many characters and also the problem
with the show is like they play with
your emotions it's like they there are
all these storylines and they make you
hate someone like Dan is evil evil and
then one day they just decided oh we're
gonna make jad nice so then you're like
feeling like am I supposed to start
liking Dan they just think you go back
and forth between how you feel about
people and how you feel about them like
Peyton with Lucas and Lucas but like
it's just it's like mind games but it's
it's really like because it was so long
ago it's the template of like a lot of
really popular shows like about high
school or it's like it's really you
could see how like it's like a it's the
only show I keep comparing it to is
forever now but it's like literally the
og Riverdale like it's just it's it you
should compare to the OC because they
were on at the same yeah so but I mean
like that it's that template of a type
of TV show that like I see now in shows
like Riverdale and like dynasty but it
was just so cringy back then like some
of the stuff and like Chad Michael
Murray he's like you know this
basketball player but Jackie he's also
you know and intellect and he like read
Stephen Archie he reads John Steinbeck
and he's just like you know really
appreciates literature and it's just
like so unrealistic I can some of the
characters make me want to die Halley
like seriously she's on that tour bus
like I hope it crashes her to comment
and I can't wait till you get to an
episode when I want to I say it's a
Grayson here yeah I want to see him how
like in the comments people are so
anyway like I've actually managed to
avoid all spoilers I feel like you know
what's annoying is like if anyone were
to ever watch friends they know like
Ross and Rachel you know like everyone
knows like that's the couple but I
haven't heard anything left I didn't
even know people's names you know for
I'm in Chad what why would you say that
I don't know why why would you say that
I don't know cuz the blonde characters
always end up together no I don't think
that they end up together I'm team
Brooke Brooke is Sophie oh sorry and
that's the most important part about
what I had came here to say is that it's
no wonder that nobody from the show ever
got famous after Jocelyn oh what's the
show called what retail because they're
honestly they're all talentless hacks
but Sophia Bush it is no wonder she's
the only person who got famous she is an
absolute star look maybe it's because
the people around her are so terrible at
acting that she's like oh wait no maybe
it's Sophia Bush and Chad I just stopped
talking because they were not married oh
that's true
well she is just I can't like I just
I've never I don't really think of her
that much in real life you know either
I never just like think about you know
Sophia Bush like she related to George
like I just don't really think about her
but in the show she is an absolute star
she makes the show bearable she is the
best character she's like the rich cool
a pretty girl but not like her parents
go bankrupt but she's just everything of
the sort she's such a good actress she's
so pretty she's so cute her outfits are
so 90s like her halter top and her flip
flops like she is everything the sort
she's the backbone of the show and I
just love her and it it makes sense to
me that she's literally the only person
whose face I recognize like you would
think this was a nine season show these
kids were stars except for try Michael
Murray but like what did any of them do
after it you wouldn't know anyone from
the show Bethany Joy Lenz do you know
her Hilary Burton no you don't know her
because they're nobodies because they're
terrible actors but Sophia Bush that's
lights also Kyle Chandler no but like
all the kids where do they go Tim
Riggins like he's very rich
wherefore out thou he goes he's just
like weird action movies all the time I
would say he's one of the top three
people who got famous from a Connie
Britton Kyle Chandler and like Matt
Saracen nobody talentless hack yeah and
George Strait Jason Street is famous
yeah Julie talentless hack she was the
whoa
actually you know who was a great
actress may she rest in peace Matt
Saracens grandma she was so cute she was
so cute leaves me up the Friday Night
Lights vibe
what about that girl Tanya Tara Oh Tara
the worst talentless hack and she's like
oh but um Minka Kelly Minka Kelly but
she also like his famous like not at all
you know she's like Sophia Bush Sophia
Bush is way more
I don't know it's like they could get a
job you don't really think of that but
she's on Chicago PD always a pleasure to
see them Chicago people consider Sophia
Bush to be like America Hargitay in the
making she's like a daytime hero
really yes she's big and Chicago it's a
Chicago PD a Chicago med I can't
remember which one but one of Chicago
shows interest I enjoy it I would say I
think you would like you know we would
love it but for some reason well watch
it a snitch I mean Margo it's yours type
of show like Indian high schoolers who
think that they're adults yeah like
that's view in a show and let me not
forget the cringe factor like you love
that [ __ ] yeah I'm like jealous of you
that you're so into a show like I think
it's a great feeling and been and know
what's really helped like dive me even
deeper into the show is having a lot of
sack o for hit for sure I felt like I
was setting up for an ad no yesterday I
was so busy that I didn't even spend a
minute in my lifestyle oh that's awful
today because I went from my feet like
to my bed that's awful oh my god today I
did my makeup and turned around the feel
was in the love sack I keep throwing him
in the club sack like so he'll think
that like it's his new home and I think
it's actually working because today he
took like a 30-minute nap event I
actually forgot he was here loves that
can be like really disorienting - it's
kind of like you're on a ship like you
just keep sinking and like if you ever
take a nap in it like you'll wake up I'm
a different planet yeah but the thing
with a lot of sec is like you have to
get it in the right formation and I
don't think mine is fully like yeah you
need to like start like punching it yeah
okay well let's recap love Rosie okay
because I didn't know anything about the
movie I had no expectations so I just
was like enjoying watching the story
play out and it wasn't my favorite movie
at all but like Lily Collins is
extraordinary extraordinary looking
she's British
know her right Phil Phil I think I think
Phil Collen see I'm gonna look it up
really quickly but like she shining
through she's an English American
actress okay wait she was born in Surrey
and moved to LA as a child what Surrey
luxury is in the UK yeah okay she like
has British roots but I don't think she
has like a regular British accent but
nobody she definitely knows how to do it
easier yeah so the movie was just like
not what I thought it was gonna be and
it turns out that it's based on a book
which I can actually see
how this would be a book that someone
would like it's similar to that book
that we all like one day in December
where it's just kind of like this -
passing ships that like never seem to
meet story which is my least favorite
type of movie yeah cuz it's like it's
even worse than everything going wrong
cuz it's like nothing can go right yeah
I generally hate movies where it's like
the two people keep missing each other
and it's so frustrating because they're
meant to be for like 15 years yeah and
they're in one place and they're in
another place but what made the what
made that type of movie even sadder was
like her life was so sad and his life
was so fabulous you know yeah but then
like at a certain point his life is so
sad and meaningless yeah and her life is
so full fulfilled yeah that's true and
by the end like her like what she gets
in the end is just like a dream the
hotel was fabulous fabulous and like I
guess they weren't ready for I don't
know it but it's also like this whole 15
years was based off of like one
misunderstanding right when they were 18
which is just a little unrealistic I
know and you know who like fascinates me
who Sookie border how was she in it yes
she was Bethenny are you sure positive
because I looked it up I was like is
that Suki Waterhouse cuz I feel like she
looks different all the time and I don't
really know what she looks like
I believe it's Suki and then I looked it
up and she is I literally don't believe
in movie and I just think she's so
interesting you're I don't know why
you're right she looks so different now
here this is why she's interesting cuz
she's like Lizzie date Bradley Cooper
her life is like a nightmare like she
literally dated Bradley Cooper and like
made him into like the fiancee he wanted
to be and then like he dumped her and
then the next girl was like the
long-term girl oh I don't see it like
that I feel like she had the pleasure of
being with Bradley Cooper and the next
girl just like they happen to have a
baby you know cuz they were together
like seriously like everyone thought
like Sookie might be the one I know but
like I think he would have been like a
forever playboy kind of guy but he had a
baby so then he had to like stick around
but they were tryna parking up anyway
maybe I just could you have seen like
Sookie next to Lady Gaga at the Oscars
like really you know she would have just
I I don't even know her that's why she's
so fast me so that's what's so
interesting is it was my understanding
that she was a model and now she is it
allegedly an actress and I just want to
know like how
got to a place to date Bradley Cooper
when I don't know her any of her
modeling work and up until now I didn't
know any of her acting work yeah like
how do you get in the Hollywood circuit
without actually working like in
Hollywood
I think she's like a socialite mm I just
think she's really interesting but I
don't know anything about I can't
believe that was her looks nothing like
her I played what actually met you know
what she looks like yes I met her once
she's a chameleon yes she is and I
didn't even think for one [ __ ] second
that Bethenny could be here like it
didn't even cross my mind hey I don't
know how it crossed my mind but I was
like is that her because I just feel
like I never know I'm never certain if
it's her you know sometimes after I
watch a movie like I'll look up that I
am to be like the people on Instagram so
maybe I would have noticed but I
genuinely didn't really love this movie
so when it was over I was just happy was
over and I went to sleep yeah anyways I
I didn't love the movie I didn't hate it
at that perfect toast movie because I
would have wanted to watch it anyway
frustrating story but I thought guy is
so cute I am yeah and I like Lily
Collins character she's so beautiful
oh my god there's nothing she can't do
no hair length she can't pull off well I
beg to differ I thought that hair lines
at the end was but when she curled it it
wasn't cute but like when it was every
other style it was cute like like at the
wedding it was terrible and then the
final scene it was terrible no I liked
the short hair and that's the only way
they could really like age her and then
it was crazy eyed she literally had a
daughter that was her age ya know the
kid was huge and what was really sad was
that Sam's like fiance who got pregnant
and like the baby wasn't his that was
really sad
yeah dad Beyonce was crazy crazy how did
he end up with a girl like her yeah that
was like the whole thing didn't make
sense it's like you went to Boston and
totally lost his identity and what was
his job even where he's you know having
these fabulous apartment and it was Nev
like he always planned on becoming a
doctor and I'm sure after the 12 years
like he was a doctor but he was like at
Harvard and had this fancy apartment
when they were just from a small town in
London like his whole financial
situation made no sense to me yeah but
then also it's like their financial
situations did make sense to me either
cuz like that house that she lived in
was like nice and then her share her
share of the sales from the house was
enough to get her that hotel on the sea
well so but she also a two brothers show
a third of the house she split the hotel
on the sea with um oh the pharmacist who
was that was literally the best
character such a good friend he's a
pharmacist put up money for the hotel I
have to assume they like fixed it up
together she was
had hotel expecting she had sweat equity
I think that they were partners well no
I think that when Lily Collins says to
her daughter like how would you feel if
I use my proceeds my share from the
house to open a little hotel she was
like I would love that for you mom he is
so I don't know what like a small
cottage in an English village a third of
it gets you but it's definitely not
enough maybe she got a loan from the
bank no but I think what I'm saying is I
think that house was really something
cuz like it also looks kind of big on
the street and then when she ran across
the street to Sam's house Sam's house
was nice Sam's house was nice but they
live on the same street so how different
could it but something lived in like a
middle-class neighborhood I never
thought about the financial I thought so
too until her share of the house and she
had two brothers so and one of them was
Rickon so wait what the brothers her
little brothers his name was ricotta
it's the same character I'm sorry wait
hold on
wow you missed all these little love
room I can't freak on which brother the
little my god you're right his name is
art Parkinson and Mike played brick home
stop [ __ ] run diagonally you're right
later zigzag rekon oh my god that's so
funny okay so she has two brothers so
she gets a third of that house Jo I'm
gonna say it was at least earning three
million dollars she at least put a
million dollars into the castle by the
sea the castle by the sea was so
fabulous so fabulous I thought she
bought it like as a house for her tour
kid I'm like that's a little extravagant
like at that point I was like not really
listening and I didn't even hear her
tell her daughter she was gonna start a
hotel and I'd forgotten because they
hadn't said since the beginning of the
movie that her dream was to start a
hotel so I'm like all right this [ __ ]
is like getting out of control like she
sells one house by the palace and I
would say yeah no but she
she lived out her dream and I think her
dad would have been really proud Oh her
dad dying was so sad
exactly and like the husband hiding the
letter while also cheating on her like
you don't get to take away a woman's joy
when you're also cheating on her yeah
that's like a special type of
douchebaggery like it's unprecedented
it's like not only can you not have
happiness with me I will not allow it
but you also can't have happiness with
anyone yeah but when she married him I
like wasn't that sad and I'm like
they're really nice hats on when Sam
came back I was like Lilly's got it
figured out by boy yeah and I love that
like she wasn't sad anymore like yeah he
I think he always saw her as I kind of
like her life just like took a different
turn than like what they had planned and
then like he came back and like she had
a family and I was really excited I
wanted that to work for her but he ended
up being a Jew yeah because like every
at different stages of their lives when
they would sync up like one of them was
always better off and it was just like
always sad when she was sad and I was
always happy when she was better off
yeah because it's like he's like a male
a straight white male like he'll find
success you know yeah and like what was
with Rosie like at the hotel telling
Bethenny to go find Alex in Boston like
what kind of [ __ ] does that well at
that point she thought she was happy you
know and she was like I want happiness
for him and I don't think she ever
thought they would get married but like
you know what's a what's a nostalgia
[ __ ] I cannot believe that that was Suki
Waterhouse that's so crazy crazy
honestly it was a movie that I never
would have seen if it weren't for the
chest movie the day so that's good I
guess but other than that it wasn't my
favorite but it wasn't bad by the way
Sam is that a name of the actor so he I
guess his name is Alex yeah sorry I keep
forgetting I'm like it's Sam Molly and
Sookie sorry Sam Lily Sookie I'm Rekha
so our toast movie of the day selection
is a Disney Plus selection it's
Confessions of a Teenage Drama Queen
starring Lindsay Lohan I'm so excited
and I haven't seen it in so long and I
just have one thing to say Jo boo bud oh
because I just feel like I just feel
like that girl was a 1time teenage drama
queen drama queen hacked up every day
wannabe and she had changed her destiny
now she's just somebody Wow that girl
was a wild child and you know what about
the myth it was called love Rosie cuz
obviously they were like corresponding a
lot but that just like did not come
through in the movie like she never once
said like love rose oh I just have to
say I just realized why it was called
love Rosie they didn't even write each
other that much but I guess in a book
they must have been corresponding and
she was always like love Rosie what I
like about watching these somewhat old
movies it's just like a reminder of how
we all used to communicate like with
instant messaging and the day they got
the Mac situation the im2 the video chat
totally right and then the 12 years like
her going from her Nokia phone to having
an iPhone like I thought the tech
it was interesting I think it'll also be
interesting when we watch Confessions of
a Teenage Drama Queen because like we
were teenagers when that movie was out
and like what were we doing on our
computers and phones uh yeah I don't
know the end Dance Revolution baby
totally I'm excited to watch out and I
know Ben's gonna want to watch it with
me because he's secret Lindsay Lohan
number one fan also we haven't discussed
that Lindsay lemon came out with new
music what are your thoughts on that
it's just like them and a buying thing
you know yeah I like Pete I ever like
I'm worship the history of Lindsay Lohan
and the archive of her work as far as
what's happening going forward I'm just
not interested
Wow okay official statement it's only a
facial statement I understand it applies
to amanda Bynes as well yeah well you
want to give me I she's a man sequel we
could talk but until then I just I have
I have new passions my favorite scooter
you know who else they feel that way
about a little bit it was like so crazy
that I'm gonna say this cuz I got one
point like she was my god who Miley
Cyrus yeah she did that her ever worship
everything she's done up until this
point but you know what I've moved on
oh you don't need a good Disney movie
Hannah Montana forever Herbie fully
loaded oh that's a really good Justin
Long
yeah that's a good one once again on
Disney class tonight I feel like I'm
gonna get really inspired it's actually
a fabulous Oh quickly can we talk about
kwibi because i downloaded it and paid
$4.99 i wasn't ready to make the $7.99
commitment i love that they give you
options it's like do you want a little
ads $4.99 no ads $7.99 yeah and it's
like that's perfect so obviously I went
on and watched Chrissy's court because
like that's what everyone's talking
about
and it watch the first two episodes and
I thought it was fabulous like the whole
concept is really funny but like
honestly I thought Chrissy was like a
really unfair judge like she was ruling
in favor and for the most part it's like
kind of like weird that she's like an
actual multi-millionaire and she's like
deciding whether or not these two people
like who live very average lives should
pay one another four thousand dollars
for a car and it feels weird in the
first episode I watched she did cover
the cost because it was so dumb like for
a nine hundred our speaker and she
covered it but the second one like she
made this guy this girl pay $3,000 and
it's just weird to like hear that from
like a celebrity do you know any mean
it's like a little tone deaf I have to
listen I have to watch my problem with
the shows like I was literally
disagreeing with her judgments 100% like
she would hear the facts ask a million
questions like it would get funny and
then she would have to
make a real decision and honestly like
she was an unfair judge I didn't agree i
watch two episodes okay I'm gonna I'm
gonna check it out
let me get three months for you so
exciting okay so that's our show y'all
yeah there's a little tienen news if you
want to head over to the trust news
network Instagram even update about one
of our shows which was date night with
Raven and Adam they've actually decided
to rebrand into girls night with Raven
and Alexis so we got a lot of really
good response from their episode
together on date night and they decided
to rebrand because Adams like super busy
they're planning the wedding they
explained it all there's three new
episodes with Raven Alexis and Adam pops
in for the first one three new episodes
explain them the whole thing and
honestly I'm just feeling like this vibe
is much more of the team like it's just
it's a it's a vibe it's a vibe yeah and
people seem to be really excited about
it so if you love Raven and Alexis from
The Bachelor about you're in paradise
head over to their new podcast their
girls tonight it's so cute so cute and
bye they only they both like run their
own businesses and they like talk so
much about like and they wake up every
day and they just like love to like do
like their businesses and they just want
like make their businesses so let poppin
it's really really sweet oh my god
that's really cute I'm excited so it's
called girls night with Raven and Alexis
it's available on Spotify and iTunes and
then we'll have new episodes this week
of all your favorite podcasts like the
snatchler maternity live mood with
Lauren Elizabeth caviar dreams with
Margaret Joseph's so yeah it's a never
ending content stream hirose news
networks make sure you're following
Actos news network and at the morning
toast on Instagram that's what we got
for you guys this has been the morning
toast millennial morning show where we
go live Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m.
Eastern Time on YouTube so if you're
watching this on YouTube currently
please subscribe to give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as a
podcast anywhere podcasts can be found
so that Spotify iTunes stitcher Public
Radio iHeartRadio cashbox all the places
so ever you listen to podcasts find us
the Marny toast and leave a five star
review about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are we love you guys very very
much
stay safe social distance and we'll see
you tomorrow bye